[Music]
Britney Spears may be heading to court
over child support pleas from ex Kevin
Federline a source close to Federline
tells et that he wants an increase in
child support from the pop star adding
Kevin wants to ask them to consider
paying an amount of child support that
would be appropriate given the
significant increase in her finances
since the singer's Las Vegas residency
and piece of meat or has been widely
successful Federline is hoping to see
that reflected in larger payments for
their kids our source says Britney
currently pays around 20 thousand
dollars a month for child support noting
that the two haven't come to an
agreement on new payments so they could
be going to court soon quote Kevin was
disappointed that they couldn't sit down
and resolve this amicably Britney's
ex-husband has had full custody of their
son Sean Preston and Jaden since 2008
and they remain amicable for the sake of
their kids the source explains Britney
and her boyfriend Sam asghari have the
ability to give the boys everything they
need adding Kevin wants to get the
appropriate child support so that he too
can pay for those things I mean we're
doing this for children et has reached
out to Federline's lawyer as well as
Spears camp for comment
[Music]
[Applause]